when you're in the upside down things
can get kind of crazy so you know there
were embarrassing moments on the
stranger things set who unintentionally
interrupted scenes which actor was the
best jokester but before we dive in you
should probably subscribe to our new
channel the things animated to get all
the hidden secrets and unique theories
behind your favorite animated movies and
shows
number one
sometimes you get what's coming to you
noah schnapp didn't know what hit him
but it was a long time coming since
while he's the biggest prankster of them
all schnapp wound up embarrassing plenty
of co-stars through practical jokes so
while filming season 4 it was time he
got a taste of his own medicine let's
set the scene so it was 4 am we were in
new mexico schnapp was busy filming
while millie bobby brown and the team
got to work we had trash bins
filled with water balloons all around
and we turned all the lights off at base
camp brown lured noah over with her
excellent acting skills no i'm just so
upset that you know you're not you're
not here to say goodbye to me please
just come back to base camp i'm leaving
now when his best friend needs him he'll
be there but instead of finding a
teary-eyed millie he got a whole crew
taking revenge on him and i get him in
the middle of the car park all of us
about 20 people raid him this cast does
not mess around with their practical
jokes
number two
their lips were sealed and i'm not gonna
name names
because it's pretty embarrassing in the
early days filming on the bus got a bit
stuffy and one person was left feeling
real embarrassed somebody farted on the
bus we were filming in and we had to
clear out for about 20 minutes but
that's not the worst of it there wound
up being two performers trying to avoid
being called out and then we got back on
after like 20 minutes of airing this
thing out and somebody else farted it
was a smelly mystery that's for sure
they tried to blame it on the initial
perpetrator that said filming that day
happened to be one of gaiden matarazzo's
absolute favorites we wonder if he's
keeping any secrets we still don't know
where that second part looks hmm
number three
this one ended in tears yikes noah
schnab and millie bobby brown wound up
being the ones embarrassed after playing
this joke on one of the crew members
that went a bit too far the actors were
bored on set one day and decided to give
the crew member a ring pretending to be
the manager of the venue where their
wedding was meant to take place just two
weeks later they thought it would be
funny to tell her that they had to
cancel the reso because of construction
but they were mortified when that crew
member wound up bursting into tears
instead you can bet the two were
blushing all day after that joke gone
wrong
number four
he's coming in there were like two
hundred people in the room just stabbed
olsen wolfhard went ahead and made his
very first kiss with millie bobby brown
on screen super awkward
coming in looking back finn isn't so
crazy about the scene it looks like i
was eating her like i was like ah was he
hoping millie would feel better about
the kiss that way
luckily that day was probably the worst
of it and it became a less embarrassing
process as they went on i will say this
it's we've we've progressed number five
the accents can be tricky charlie heaton
is always professional and his american
accent is on point but funnily enough he
has a whole lot of trouble with one name
and it's one he really should be able to
say they've dated on and off screen so
the fact that heaton really struggles to
say the name nancy properly leaves him
blushing constantly on set to make
matters worse he actually had to come in
for separate recording sessions to
re-record any time he said nancy so it
sounded right in the final edit
number six
this is never not awkward but it's
especially bad when it happens to be
your first kiss in real life too i mean
i guess technically would be the one
that was in stranger things to make it
all worse caleb mclaughlin and sadie
sink were not expecting it
there wasn't a word about this happening
in the script or talks beforehand but
the day of the actors were put on the
spot and the pressure was on it's a lot
of kids just like
you're going to kiss her
poor sadie sank also had to deal with
the fact that her mom happened to be
there to witness it all has there ever
been a more embarrassing first kiss
scenario
in front of like so many people yeah
that was that was it
number seven clothing in the 80s was
different finn wolfhard had a real hard
time when he was handed a classic pair
of tidy whities a la 80s for him to wear
in case his underwear was showing from
under his pants on the show the actor
was so embarrassed at the thought he
didn't even give them a chance insisting
to his co-stars
i'm not wearing these i'm just gonna
wear my real things my real underwear
number eight
you do what you gotta do that's the
motto that caleb mclaughlin has learned
to roll with being part of the stranger
things cast he was very excited to film
the scene early on that saw him sneaking
up on his pal but then this happens
that part wasn't so fun but he was
always a professional about it despite
his feelings as an actor you do it you
do it you do it you love the art you do
it and that's why i did it
number nine
it's a look
playing a kid in the 80s isn't all it's
cracked up to be especially in the hair
department season three was this huge
wig and season four it was these little
extensions and noah schnapp never knew
what he was going to get from the wig
team what he could guarantee was the
fact that he'd be real embarrassed to be
wearing those wigs on set no matter what
he was given
number 10
no one wants to call attention to
themselves this way remember the smelly
situation that happened on the bus well
it happened again in the series but
instead of distracting everyone with the
stench it was a fully audible situation
caleb mclaughlin was the guilty one in
this case and it was much harder to get
out of since the whole set was pretty
quiet and gabe monrozzo had been right
next to him meaning he heard everything
matarazzo struggled to keep his cool
explaining we were dying but we couldn't
laugh out loud because they were doing a
really dramatic scene in there talk
about awkward timing
number eleven
caleb mclaughlin is even more talented
than we thought when it comes to
multitasking this actor is king always a
jokester on set he decided to see what
would happen if during the middle of a
take he blew his nose while eating an
apple at the same time don't ask us why
he did it it seems like he was just
moved to spice things up no one
understood what he was doing and he did
make a bit of a fool of himself but it
worked out well since on camera it was
pretty hilarious
number 12
maintaining composure is tougher than
you'd think it was a it was four like 12
year olds all together drinking
coca-cola and eating old pizza yeah that
just sounds like a recipe for disaster
for
six hours filming playing games together
was a pretty childlike vibe and the team
did encourage a chilled environment so
they could get the very best out of the
kids but it was still pretty high strung
who can blame them though it was the
very early days what better day to have
the giggles than your first day at work
for the first scene of the first season
number 13. what's in a name really well
in this one there's a whole lot we know
him as caleb mclaughlin but on set he's
known as chocolate daddy okay at least
that's what he refers to himself as on
set and while it's cool in the moment
the actor wasn't so crazy about the
world knowing after he let the secret
slip during an interview
number 14. to be late is to be fired
yikes millie bobby brown has regularly
proven she's an absolute professional in
the business but she didn't leave such a
great impression when she showed up to
the set for filming stranger things a
full hour late and since she's one of
the stars it didn't affect just her the
whole production schedule was thrown off
we can't imagine she was too proud of
that one
number 15
you never know which word will throw you
off for david harbour it was
it's your grandma
the actor usually oh so calm cool and
collected was the embarrassment of the
day as he turned out blooper after
blooper after blooper unable to get
through the scene without breaking
character with this crew it was hard not
to laugh
okay we're in stitches how about you
those were some pretty mortifying
experiences but in the end it seems like
they all managed to have a good laugh
which situation do you think was most
embarrassing